painful
you'd have to know so listen now I'm
sure we all know what occurred this
morning my personal opinion is that you
all know why standing this do I think
justice was served
no where do I think justice is I think
this city is still older an apology and
let me digress for a month when I came
on this job I've been a cotton out for
about 31 years and I came on this job I
came on with my honor my integrity and
my reputation someone accused me of
doing anything that was circumvent that
then I would want my day in court
period to clear my name
I've heard that they wanted their day in
court with TV cameras so America could
know the truth and though they chose to
hide behind secrecy and broker a deal to
circumvent the judicial system my job as
a police officer is to investigate an
incident gather evidence
gather the facts and present them to the
state's attorney that's what we did I
stand behind the detectives
investigation
I'll let Mary manin comment further one
thing is not only do I support the hard
work of our police officers but
effective units I like to remind
everybody a grand jury indicted this
individual based on a only a piece of
the evidence that the police had
collected in that period of time so a
grand jury actually brought the charges
I think I'm two things I'd like to serve
three things I like to say one on
financial cost us $10,000 doesn't even
come close to what the city's spent in
resources to actually look over the
camera gather all the data gather all
information that actually brought the
indictment by the grand jury I'm many
many multiple different charges second
is what I would call the ethical costs
and the ethical cost is you have as a
person who was in the House of
Representatives at dealt with hate
crimes putting him on the books that
President Obama then signed into law to
then use those very laws and the
principles and values behind the Matthew
Shepard hate crimes legislation to
self-promote your career is advised a
cost that comes to all the individuals
gay men and women who will come forward
and one day would say they were a victim
of a hate crime who now will be doubted
people of faith Muslim or any other
religious faith who will be a victim of
hate crimes people that of also of all
walks of life and backgrounds race
ethnicity sexual orientation
now this cast a shadow of whether
they're telling the truth and he did
this all in the name of self-promotion
and he used the laws of the hate crime
legislation that all of us collectively
over years and put on the books to stand
up to be the values that embody what we
believe in this is a whitewash of
justice a grand jury could not have been
clearer
do then say not only is the cost $10,000
doesn't come cause financially but all
the other repercussions of this decision
it made to me where is the
accountability in the system you cannot
have because of a person's position one
set of rules apply to them and another
set of rules apply to everybody else in
another way you're seeing this play out
in the universities where people pay
extra to get their kids a special
position in universities now you have a
person because of their position and
background who's getting treated in a
way that nobody else would ever sorry
about that would don't get in here I'm
doing there my sermon here get close to
this type of treatment our officers did
hard work day in and day out countless
hours working to unwind what actually
happened that night the city saw its
reputation dragged through the mud but I
remind everybody it was not just the
officers work that work a piece of that
work was shown to a grand jury and they
made a decision based on only a sliver
of the evidence and I remember correctly
somebody wanted to have that evidence
and the day as the superintendent said
their day in court so all the evidence
can be made public because of the
judge's decision
none of that evidence will ever be made
public
none of it this is without a doubt a
whitewashed justice and sends a mat
clear message that if you're in a
position of influence and power you'll
get treated one way other people will be
treated another way there is no
accountability than in the system it is
wrong full-stop
what I do want to say is I the way I
look at is I commend the officers and
the grand jury for their decisions you
know at the end of the day like I said
our job as police officers is to present
them with the evidence the apology comes
from the person that did this if you
want to say you're innocent of a
situation then you take your day in
court I would never
if someone falsely accused me I would
never hide behind a brokered deal and
secrecy period I don't know what's
unusual for the state's attorney but we
found out about when you are did John
from that firm - its hold on wants I
would say one thing from top to bottom
this is not on the level I understand
that piece but I do want to get it's not
on the level but I also want to say and
I want to emphasize underscore what the
superintendent just said in the end of
the day it's mr. Smollett that committed
this false claim upon two individuals
and who also testified but also on the
city one action yes you're looking at
the state's attorney it is not on the
level from beginning to end and there
needs to be a level of accountability
throughout the system and this sends an
unambiguous message that there is no
accountability and that is wrong
and your department on cases every day
well you know prosecutors have their
discretion of course we still have to
work with the state's attorney's office
I'm sure we'll have some conversation
after this but again at the end of the
day it's mr. Smollett who committed this
this this whole period if he wanted to
clear his name
the way to do that was in a court of law
so that everyone could see the evidence
you all know what the bond prophets said
you know we all nobody said so you know
I stand by the facts of what we produced
if they want to dispute those facts then
the place to do that is in court not
sure I wanted to say one other thing mr.
Smollett is still saying that he is
innocent still running down the Chicago
Police Department how dare him how dare
him after everybody saw and I want to
remind you this is not the
superintendence word against his the
grand jury a sliver of the evidence and
they came to a conclusion as did the
state's attorney's office this is not
the superintendent and the detectives
department word against his and even
after this whitewash Stier still no
sense of ownership of what he's done he
says that in fact he is the wronged in
this case this is an unbelievable not
just white watch of justice this is a
person now who's been let off scot-free
with no sense of accountability of the
moral and ethical wrong of his actions
from top to bottom
not only just virtually the name of the
city but then I cannot stress that in a
time when you have people bringing a
moral equivalency in Virginia between
bigots and those fighting bigotry then
you have a person using hate crime laws
that are on the books to protect people
who are minorities from violence
- then turn around and use those laws to
advance your career and your financial
reward is there no decency in this man
two things one - the state's attorney -
the skirts attorney the question about
whether it was politically motivated or
not it's something you have to ask them
because they only they can answer their
motivation but I do know what the grand
jury says and I keep pointing you back
to where the grand jury did when they
saw just a piece of the data and I and I
think there's not a person up here we'd
love to have all the information made
public let alone the two individuals who
also talked wait a second it's not
matter whether I do or not that's a
question that only she can answer I can
only guess at it to your question sure I
would just if you mind repeating it
because I cut it
he's a person he's a person that brought
this forward now I remind you all he
goes back to also a letter now he
brought this case forward he said he was
a victim of a hate crime well for his
sexual orientation and for being black
the evidence came forward a grand jury
saw the evidence realized this was a
hoax a hoax on the city a hoax on hate
crimes a hoax on people of good values
who actually were empathetic at first
and he used that empathy for only one
reason just listen I'm going to close on
this we just had one of the largest
ceremonies for the police department in
the history of the city two hundred
ninety seven men and women most diverse
class representing all parts of this
city people from all walks of life and
backgrounds and faiths who said they
want to serve the city and serve the
values of the city and help serve others
in time in need they are there to uphold
the law and they had their best training
to do that and I draw the you in that
contrast people of all walks of life as
I said graduates of our public schools
kids who grew up in parents where police
officer veterans of the Armed Forces who
have a life of service they were there
to not only uphold the law but the
values that imbue and inform those laws
and now you have an individual who took
those laws turned him inside out upside
down for only one thing himself and that
in my view it's an insult and an offense
to every one of us who collectively
uphold those laws because they reflect
who we are as a city and because of the
hate crime legislation that's federal
who they who we are as a country thank
you